is there any daily disciplines that you
have in your life daily routines that
you would attribute to your success yeah
I try to beat the Sun up I write my
goals down every day I try to hit the
gym so I don't do it perfect every day
some things throw me off I create a
lifestyle where some things are taken
care of for me that most people don't
have that option you know somebody
drives the kids to school I don't have
to do that that would change everything
if I had to do that who knows maybe I
need to maybe I need to start driving
the kids to school it seems like a
complete waste of time to make so when I
bounce out of here I got to go do a live
stream on real estate but yeah that
that's the first three things if I can
get that done in the morning man I know
I'm gonna have a good day yeah pretty
simple beat the beat the Sun up make
sure you write down your goals yeah make
sure you take care of yourself get the
blood flow and get the heart pumping
like I write them down today like I had
never written them down before so simple
on the outside but so many people won't
do I dare everybody listening here to
try to do it for 30 days in a row see if
you can even make seven staying
consistent on your morning routine
is the difference between you having
a good life and a great life the life
that you're living right now which is
good listen you have a good life right
now if you're watching this you have
internet you have food you know you have
a place to sleep tonight you have a you
have a pretty good life
you have a pretty good life but it's not
a great life
you know you know you're capable of more
you know you want to do more you know
that where you are right now is not
where you want to be that imagine a year
two years five years imagine if you were
still in the same spot in five years
imagine your life your health your
relationships your finances the impact
you're having your your routine your
daily like what you're doing on a
regular and nothing has changed in five
years
still be a good life but it's not a
great life
right it's not a great life
this is the struggle that you know
you're capable of so much more if you
didn't know you're capable of more
ignorance is bliss you just keep living
your life
but when you know you're capable of more
this is the the curse of the Achievers
like you know you're capable of so much
more no matter how much people look at
you and say hey wow you're doing so well
you're doing so much that's that's why
you're watching these videos you are the
most ambitious person that you know
people look to you for guidance and
wisdom advice and support and
encouragement and hope and inspiration
like you're the one filling other people
up you're the one inspiring other people
to do better to be more to go after
their dreams that's you but who's doing
that for you
you know you're capable of so much more
and so how do you get it how do you how
do you do the work well it's a daily
thing this is this is part of the
challenge is it's a daily thing it gets
boring
it gets boring
to do the exact same thing every day
to stay consistent on what you said you
were going to do
and we start to doubt ourselves
you have days where you're motivated
inspired ready to Take On The World
feeling amazing and other days where you
don't feel so good and you think wake up
feeling like who am I I can't do this
what I said I was gonna do that you look
at your goals like I'm gonna I'm gonna
do that there's no way I'm gonna do that
me
I'm gonna stay in bed
it's a thing Achievers don't talk about
is there's a lot of days when you just
don't feel like you're worthy of it you
don't believe in yourself you don't
think that you can do it
and it's just that consistency that
prevents you from doing the thing
because you'll have the days when you're
on fire and then entire days maybe weeks
sometimes where you're just not doing
anything
and so how do you how do you keep that
momentum how do you keep that
consistency it starts with a morning
routine
and the goal of a morning routine
is to help you feel
motivated bold courageous ready to take
on the day that's what the goal of a
morning routine is
everybody's got a morning routine if
you're watching this you got a morning
team everybody doesn't have a morning
routine most people actually wake up
like an accident right most people wake
up and they fall into their day and they
look at their phone and it's other
people's emergencies and other people's
demands for your time that's most
people's day but for you if you're
watching this
you're you're an achiever and you have
some kind of morning routine but most
people's morning routine are also broken
because you're not doing it consistently
enough or you're not doing it with
enough intent
so if you ask what's the goal of a
morning routine
the gold of morning routine is to get
you bold and prepped and ready for the
day let me ask you this if you were to
for the next year of your life right 365
days the next year of your life you're
going to wake up
and do something that would make you
feel bold powerful courageous motivated
not asking you to wake up feeling bold
powerful courageous motivated but to
wake up tired however you wake up
I woke up tired today you wake up
and then you do something that will help
you feel bold powerful motivated
courageous and ready to take on the day
if you woke up into debt for the next
365 how much is your life changing how
much is the next year change how much
does the does the impact that you're
making does the actual momentum that
you're taking towards your goals how
much does that change
it for the next year you actually did
that
it should be tremendously it should be
dramatically because no matter how much
you do in your morning routine one
you're probably not super consistent on
it and two you're not getting the
feeling even if you are
that's what needs to change
I was in New Mexico
and I was doing uh on Super Bowl Sunday
my workshop and it was the smallest
group on our tour and we're talking
about morning routines and there was a
woman there and I asked her what what's
the most important part of your morning
routine and she said prayer I said so
you pray how often do you pray every day
every day every day praise your praise
perfect how often do you feel
the prayer how often do you feel the
connection and how often are you just
saying the words
and she said like half the time
great
other people might look to her and say
well look you do it every day even for
herself she might look in herself and
say great I did it every day as
Achievers we like to check the box right
you like to check the box I did it I did
it I did it I did it I did it I prayed I
watched the video I read the book I
brushed my teeth I whatever you have
your checklist and you did it right and
you feel great that you did it but if
you don't get the feeling
of courageousness and you just check the
box it doesn't count
so watching a video might be part of
your morning routine
great I I'm you know if it's mine I'm
honored to be a part of your journey but
somebody else is amazing do that too
but if you know that watching the video
is the thing that helps make you feel
alive bold confident
you know that there are some days that
watching a video actually makes you feel
that way and other days where it doesn't
and you know that watching the same
video over and over and over and over
every day will lose its impact super
quick right day one you're motivated day
two already you've lost like 80 of the
motivation that you got from day one day
three it's basically over you run it for
a month forget it like you've already
memorized the words that the words don't
mean anything to you anymore
so you have to have some variety
and if you're watching the video while
you're doing something else
this is the achiever's curse you're
watching the video while you're brushing
your teeth while you're taking the dogs
out while you're cleaning the sink while
you're making the bed you're distracted
you're doing something else you're
trying to multitask right here's what
happened to the achievers
you still get to check the box to say
that you watch the video
but because you weren't present for the
video guess what happens there was no
retention there was no feeling you don't
feel ready to take on the day you don't
feel the boldness to courageousness and
therefore you don't go and have a great
day even though you checked off
everything on your morning routine
that's what makes a difference
so if you get to the end of your morning
routine and you don't feel bold powerful
courageous ready to go for the day
there's one of two things that you have
to do one is you audit your morning
routine you say What's missing
you know like does this still work for
you anymore what's missing do I need to
add something in do I need to add an
espresso video in during the morning do
I need to add reading do I need to add
working out do I need to add writing my
goals down like what do you need to do
to add and tweak and experiment and see
if it makes you feel better or two
maybe you just need to do the routine
again but with more intention maybe you
did the whole routine while you were
distracted
maybe you did the whole routine while
you're thinking something else
so you don't get the feeling there's
nothing wrong with the routine the
routine is great
routine is perfect for you
but if you don't show up with intention
if you don't show up and be focused on
it you're not going to get the feeling
you could sit there and be in the chair
you know think about going to classes
going to school you could sit there be
in the chair doesn't mean that you're
going to learn
you can sit there and watch a video but
if you're brushing your teeth and doing
eight other things
you're not going to get the feeling
this is the loving push forward that I
hope you accept
because everybody else is going to look
at you and see how much you're doing and
how perfect you are and how much
momentum you have and how many things
you're doing and they look up to you in
awe and you're an inspiration to them
and you should be because you are doing
amazing things
and at the same time you know it's
nothing compared to what you could do
but the difference between where you are
right now where you want to go is
actually not that big
the difference is just minor tweaks
between where you are right now where
you want to go for most of you it's just
minor tweaks
this is one of those minor tweaks
that if you could just stay consistent
on having a morning routine
and then inside of that consistency
doing the thing that makes you feel bold
powerful Unstoppable alive ready to
start the day not expecting to be
amazing when you wake up but then doing
the thing that brings that out of you
every single day your life
will change also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
I understand the affirmations and mental
and be positive and meditation how about
some action yeah
you know like like you know I have never
thought something into existence without
doing something this is why I don't buy
houses okay this is what Brandon's seen
this presentation before okay this is my
favorite Topic in the universe
because because this this is what allows
me this is what allows me to move okay
so when I buy 15 when I take 15 million
dollars
okay I buy 60 million dollars worth of
Real Estate
15 million
buys 60 million for the real estate okay
okay
well and we we I'm not buying I'm not
buying 60 million dollar deals so I'm
buying
I'm buying I'll I'll do I'll do a
billion dollars worth of real estate
this year okay y'all can y'all look at
that number
okay this is what I'm gonna do this year
so I'm going to take 300 million dollars
this year
and I'm going to buy 1.2 billion dollars
worth of Real Estate
to me it's a good deal
I can become a billionaire
I can own a billion control a billion
dollars worth of assets
for 300 million all I got to do is
figure out how to get 300 million
dollars
goddamn this is like God this is all the
math I needed I could have learned this
in a fifth grade
don't need any any I don't need any
algebra no trigonometry calculus don't
need any of it this multiplication
leverage 300 million dollars worth of
cash buys 1.2 billion dollars worth of
real estate in America okay that 300
million dollars is going to pay me 18
million dollars a year
in cash flow
is that right I think that's right
I'm going to get paid 1.5 million
dollars every month
to control 1.2 billion dollars worth of
real estate okay this is cash flow cash
flow is what
Freedom baby it's Freedom it's flow it's
current it's a current currency the word
currency comes from current
if you look it up in the dictionary
current it has to move
see this right here the 1.2 billion is
not moving
that's good too though that's good
because you want something that's this
illiquid that will grow right this is
the flow the flow allows me to keep the
asset until it appreciates we're looking
for unusual activity
okay there's unusual activity going on
right now
it you see it every day if you're
looking for it people are moving out of
New York
entire companies are starting to move
New Jersey they're complaining about it
okay they're pissed off at sale the
government they change the rules on
um writing your state taxes up against
your federal
now what's that called uh salt
so it used to be that I paid 13 in
California and then I'm paying 48 in in
Federal I could take the 13 off the 48.
now it's not like that now it's 13 and
48 or 38 or 39 whatever is terrible
okay so I take 300 million dollars
it's cash
it's worth the last 10 years from now I
believe this 300 million is worth less
than 10 years
you don't need another math class it's
you know it's going down to value
I take the cash the trash
and I buy concrete steel and glass
where people live okay we don't buy any
retail nothing no Macy's no
Bloomingdale's maybe one day but not
today
these people have to have a place to
live when we buy this asset it is Cash
flowing
we know it's going to make us six
percent in in the first year five to
seven percent somewhere in that range we
should be paid on that deal okay so so
this is really important this cash flow
right here this cash flow is what will
get you through a contraction you have
to have cash flow to assist you through
contraction training
if you're not going to train then put a
sign on your desk I quit learning a long
time ago and see how many people want to
buy from
tell your family go home and tell your
wife and your kids I quit learning I
quit reading I quit studying I quit
training I can't get any better
put on there done I'm finished I'm in
retirement early I'm going to Purgatory
I'm going to wait it out cross my
fingers and hope they bring me to sales
heaven
look you're done if you don't train okay
now I know you know this you've heard it
I hate to tell you this my boy McGregor
Connor Conor McGregor or McGregor my boy
Conor McGregor okay I went and saw him
fight in New York I went and saw him
fight for one reason because I saw him
say I'm not the best this isn't about
Talent it's cause I'm obsessed I out
train everyone else I have to win so bad
I train look if you're not training that
says something about your obsession or
lack of obsession with winning
I want you to win I know your your wife
or your husband your spouse your family
members your kids your mom and dad want
you to win at the next level no matter
what they tell you even if they tell you
you're doing great patch you in the back
you know the truth
you know the truth the only way to win
is to train the only way to win is to
read the only way to win is to learn
learn more listen more learn something
new look we're in a we're in a time like
we've never been before Technologies
come and go faster than people do
things are changing like this whether
it's video you're using or social media
or snap or or short videos or videos
that disappear or videos that stay or
text messaging that you can create to
push and market and brand yourself
called text messaging which I've been
using a lot
look the world's changing and if you're
saying to yourself I'm too old to learn
that well then guess what you're too old
to learn that if you can't learn
anything new just put I'm ripe and I'm
about to fall off the tree and nobody's
gonna want me look look man you got to
train every single day like your life
depends on it
train every single day I am here today
I own these four companies that I own
the studio my reputation everything is
because when I was 25 years old to the
to when I was 30 years old every single
day I trained watching video every day
I'd watch the video I'd walk in and then
I would role play and then we would do a
sales meeting every single day when I
was a kid Glenn I was like
I knew I was going to do something great
and had zero
reason to believe that right
like it was a total fantasy
or maybe not
I think everybody has that I would
imagine that every kid
um
has this idea that they're they're
they're meant for greatness
I know I did I always thought I was
going to be something great I remember
my twin brother uh he he would he'd be
in the mirror man he's like eight years
old we're eight years old he's singing
in the mirror like he's a rock star
right I had to listen to that all the
time and and then I started thinking man
man if he's going to be a rock star
what he's going to go on and be a big
rock star
and and and I can't you know because I
that that that wasn't my deal I said
what am I going to be
and then I thought I'm gonna be a
baseball player I actually believed I
was going to be a baseball player right
dude I wasn't fast enough I wasn't
strong enough I didn't have the arm I
mean I had no Talent
I didn't have the work ethic you know I
didn't have somebody pushing me so
I've just always underestimated what I
could do I think everybody does that
that's why this 10x thing that's why I
keep telling people man you're you're
thinking too small when I talk to people
about real estate don't do two units
gotta start somewhere no you don't have
to start with two units you could
actually start with 32. right
and and by the way it's going to be a
lot easier to make money on 32 than it
is too sure if if you can just believe
that you can
you know and right now is a time where
people are going to have to start
believing they can do something else
because we're going to move into a
period of time now
where there's going to be massive
transition enforced transition on
everyone I don't think that people burn
out
I think it's impossible not I'm not a
piece of wax I'm not a candle so the
burnout thing was put on us
by people that quit already yeah you're
gonna burn out dude you're going to burn
out burnout is never about work nobody
burns out because they work too hard oh
you're burning the candle at both ends
I'm a spiritual being I can create
energy this is an irresponsibility
like I've never met a human being that
was made of wax
you know oh yeah but yeah I'm burning in
both ends you're you're a being you're a
being okay like quit saying something's
happening to you this goes back to cause
and effect I create energy
and I love your example of the kids okay
that kid can play that game it's always
a game though yeah all day all night
it's always a game there's nothing that
entertains people more than a game and
so when I was uh 18 years old man I was
playing a game called asteroids I would
play I would play eighty dollars of it a
day because it cost a quarter every game
right and I'm just popping throwing them
in doing anything I can to get quarters
so I can dump them into this into this
game
and I was trying to get to the next
level look at how people play Candy
Crush 700 levels and they're still
looking for the next level over and over
again it's games man and that energy
doesn't run out until you hit boredom
because you can see a kid play a game
too long and then they start getting
like kind of smashed in and their
attitude gets bad because they've been
playing that same game too long yeah so
I know that as long as I'm interested
not for me not passionate
for me well for me for me I need to be
able to Win It Again
if there's a chance I can win
I'll be excited about the game
if there's no chance to win I have no
interest
so for me for me the idea that I'm going
to follow my passions is a little bit
deluded for me yeah I I think people are
looking for their passion I would not
follow my passion I would I would follow
the wins right so are you saying there's
things that you could really enjoy but
you don't think you could win is that
what you mean I I think if if yeah I
think that if you're
if there's no victory
the passion is is a little bit
um
narcissistic like oh I'm gonna I'm meant
to be a artist
maybe ain't nobody buying your art
nobody's buying it all you do is stack
an art
okay who is so selfish I do this for me
makes me feel good seven million people
on this planet man yeah like if you keep
all this to yourself sooner or later
you're still gonna look like a junkyard
around you and at some point you're
going to see this person cave in in
depression and and it's like like
where's the where's where where do you
get the art out
like you know like I love watches right
so do I yeah yeah most of my watches end
up on somebody else's arm yeah like I
like I have it for a while I love it for
a while and then I'm like here you have
it yeah and so for me like it needs to
get out and and
um I have a victory in that yeah I see
it on somebody else's arm it makes me
happy yeah and and so if if I write a
book
and the book doesn't get sold I'm not
going to be excited about that book I
need the book and hands of other people
I've created a fund called Quantum
capital and it it's changing the way
people can invest in real estate so when
I was growing up
and even in my early real estate career
I could not buy the best assets the the
best properties
are left for institutions and Banks and
and it's super super wealthy I'm not
talking about
I'm talking about the kind of wealthy
you're familiar with about and read
about here and I'm not talking about
people that have hundreds of millions
but billions and hundreds of billions
and even trillions of dollars of
available money to them and so most
people
most even real estate professionals get
the leftovers everything after that and
so I've been playing the real estate
game for 30 years and in the last seven
years figured out okay I'm gonna start
buying what JP Morgan buys and
Blackstone
and I'm going to use my audience on
Instagram and Facebook and I'm not going
to go get my money from the institutions
I'm going to get the deal from the
institution
and the money is going to come from my
friends and we're going to crowdsource
this money
without paying Brokers the Brokers never
like to hear me say this but we've
raised 300 million dollars bought a
billion dollars worth of real estate in
the last 30 months I paid not one penny
job broker wow so that means all that
investor dollars ends up in the
investment
saving the investor money and then we
distribute cash distributions every
single month
not every quarter like the banks
distribute every quarter or Reit a reap
will distribute every quarter it's funny
you know people talk about the power of
social media and they they diss it a lot
but then last week last week Kylie
Jenner yeah 600 million dollars 51 stake
in her business you have raised 300
million dollars through crowdfunding
because a lot of people are wasting time
on social media they're getting the
likes and comments I know there's a guy
flying into town tomorrow and he's big
on free and don't monetize and and he's
looking at his likes and comments and I
don't look at likes and comments I look
at hey I have an offer
this is what you could do it's a great
deal for you it's a great deal for me
it's a great deal for everybody that
plays and we want to monetize so I think
I'm going to raise three billion I'm
going to create a 10 billion dollar fund
crowds funding and then the banks are
going to come to me and say we want to
buy that thing I was making some money
like in my 30s and 40s I made you know I
made a lot of money what what other
people would call a lot of money yeah
but I was not a business you know what I
mean I was just what do you mean by that
well I was just hustling
everything was a transaction yeah
everything everything was a transaction
to get money pay the taxes have a little
bit of money left over everything was in
a transaction yeah and um and this guy's
like well you know you're not a business
and I was like I know man I know don't
tell anybody I know that okay like I
knew it and because because to me a
business is I can walk away from it
it'll still operate
I was I was a guy I was no different
than when I was 30 just pounding doors
and which was good which was good and I
think a lot of people need to you don't
need to skip that spot either
because once I put the two together okay
I can pound the door I can learn
e-commerce
um I can be I can be a one product sale
I can sell it to companies like today
we'll sell we'll sell a product to a
company for 80 grand on a on a three to
five year contract 80 grand a year
and I'll switch immediately and sell an
eight dollar product online or I'll give
something away for free
to speaking to 4 000 people today in
hopes that I can meet
you know maybe 40 of them that I can do
have a partnership and a collaboration
with in the future
so like you said 10 years ago people
someone said to you you don't have a you
don't have a business what what changed
like like how have you built what you've
built now like yeah well is that when
the whole 10x philosophy well yeah
exactly connect 10x 10x woke me up 10x
was not for for the public 10x was for
me I was trying to figure out why am I I
work hard I got great products got a
great reputation great reviews people
like me they like my content
they like my content actually better
than they like me and that might have
been an exaggeration you know what I
mean and and uh
but but even if they didn't like me
they're like dude your content's so
ridiculous it's so good like whether
it's sales closing marketing promotion
and a lot
alone advice
like like I was given advice and not
taking it so when the economy crashed
which was I guess almost 10 years ago
in America particularly
it was so devastating that if you had
any weakness in a business like every
weakness would show show you know Warren
Buffett talks about hey what are you
wearing When the tide goes out well dude
in 2008 9-10 When the tide went out
every weakness that I had exhibited
hard work did not did not leave you less
vulnerable in 2010.
you could have worked hard and still
you'd be upside down in your house you
could lose everything your cash accounts
are garbage stock got wrecked everything
right so 2010 was really The Whisper
you're not a business son
that that that was the big you're not a
business and and that's when I made a
decision okay I'm gonna build a business
so between six and nine I'm gonna set up
my first three things to do that morning
I'm probably going to work out in my
case because I'm a father I'm gonna
spend time with my kids then I'm gonna
come back I'm going to take a shower I'm
going to get ready have some breakfast
and be ready for a 9 A.M meeting nine to
noon between nine and noon maybe I have
phone calls maybe I'm working on a
project maybe I'm shooting a video I'll
basically have those notes again every
line every line on this page should be
filled up noon I'm gonna take a quick
lunch maybe 10 or 15 minutes have a bite
to eat or I'm gonna spend a longer lunch
but it'll always be with a client three
to six six to nine I'm cranking down I'm
turning it off I'm going to sleep if you
over commit and under deliver if you
can't get to everything that's better
than having blank space on this calendar
now the right side is why I built the
10x planner as a Journal schedule
planner day timer day Runner call it
what you want your goals these four five
lines right here are going to be the
most important way to start your day
because this is your purpose this is why
you're living your life this is the
reason you're getting up and going into
work each day underneath this you're
going to see quote of the day
what is your quote today this is a very
creative two lines that's going to cause
you to think about what you stand for
that day these are your targets things
you want to accomplish this day calls
you want to make appointments you want
to have deals you want to close people
you need to see somebody you got to get
in front of this is your exact target
something measurable then what do we
have successes so so important don't
wait till the end of the week or the end
of the month to write down your
successes what you do today you went to
the dentist and had your teeth clean
boom that's a success for me that's a
major success because I hate being
Dennis and by the way make sure when you
put your successes down here tweet me
every once in a while and I'll make sure
I either retweet you or I follow you or
I'll get you more followers last thing
right your goal is down again you wrote
them down this morning you wrote them
down at night I can't tell you how
valuable this is okay you write your
goals down once a year I'm going to
write mine down 700 times a year who
wins this game a guy smarter than me
taller than me better looking than me
better connected then me writes his
goals down once or twice a year and I
write mine down 700 times a year who
wins it won't be taller it won't be
richer it won't be better looking it'll
be the guy that writes his goals down
twice a day every day the idea here is
look commit
okay and this is the problem with the
schooling system everything's got to be
figured out first I got to read the
instructions first like nobody really
does read this I never read this I wrote
an article about it I don't read any
instructions you know and so I mean I
can't even I can't read them because
they're so small so so uh and even when
I could read them I'm like I don't want
to read the instructions can't they make
this simpler yeah so and that is the
premise there yeah can't it just be
simpler yeah and the way to make it
simple is and we see this happening
today I mean this is happening on a
global scale where
picking a car up now simple pick me up I
don't have to put the address in it
should locate where I am car picks me up
I put in the destination tells guy where
to go don't even need a pay for it
either I don't have to sit up like
simple you guys got everything should be
simplified and the way to simplify
things I remember Mercedes ben years ago
I heard about this when they had first
figured out how to put a drop back a
hard top uh convertible into the trunk
they had never they couldn't figure it
out it used to be these old you know
they'd hang them up in the garage and
take them off and it was like very
laborious and somebody at Mercedes-Benz
said
don't tell me what it's going to cost
tell me when it's done just get it done
no matter what this is how the Elon Musk
are thinking today you know this is why
Apple keeps creating a crazy product why
this will go away somebody's going to
come along one day and say get rid of
the phone
and I still want to communicate yeah and
it'll probably be on a headset more like
this we'll probably we'll probably go in
here right where I probably I mean the
watches yeah they're they're moving
there right it's crazy so to where I
don't even need to watch I won't need
anything it's like okay I want to call
Baba we're moving in that direction of
less and faster and simpler so the way
the human being does that he's in
Brisbane the spawn the Gold Coast
I got to get down there he's committed
he doesn't figure he he just gets flight
no research
no no you weren't researching it last
night no not at all if you don't care
less if you don't know about this last
night you'd have been you'd have been
doing work about it last night planning
negotiating with the airlines when you
get compressed on time and you got a
commitment you're like I got to be there
at 2 30. everything works out
yeah as I was walking out my my
assistant she goes oh where where are
you going to stay
and I was like
book me a place we're close to you know
to the to the park on where you're
staying won't put that out but um we're
on this trip we went to Tokyo because
things don't work out as planned anyway
yeah so I'm not saying go through life
unplanned I have 500 employees so
there's got to be some planning there's
got to be is that stretched over you it
doesn't need to be me doing the planning
though yeah like I need maybe I need
somebody else to do that I don't have to
do that no I just need to know where I
want to go so we were coming to Sydney I
knew I had this commitment with success
resources to come here and do these
events good tell me when the events are
by my bank
um okay I gotta get there right so a
week ago I'm like okay hey Lanny I
called my pilot I want to route to
Sydney but let's stop in Hawaii
uh let's go to Kauai uh kids have never
been there we'll stay there for three
days acclimate for a second and shoot
down to Sydney I had enough data to know
that I would need to do a route like
that storm comes in I can't get a I
can't for some reason I can't get a the
place I want in Kauai
storm comes across the south of the
Pacific
and
uh Laney said hey we might want to be
careful with this storm coming down
there I said okay well let me just let's
reroute the Fiji double storm pops up
double-headed cyclone
okay in our path he's like Grant we
can't go that way we'd have to go all
the way around this storm I said no we
don't go to Tokyo now the point of that
story is look just keep moving forward
keep moving in a direction that you want
to go to we go to Tokyo I made all these
friends in Tokyo I would have never done
that but I was committed to going to
Sydney and and so again commit move in
the direction that gets you closer to
where you're going to go how do you
personally know like when is it time to
Pivot a little bit when is it time to
shift I've seen you put layer on layer
on layer on layer but how do you know
when to make that move when do we go to
the next layer
well for me it's you know
it's it's it's
like you see you see the end of
something coming
you know everything's got a cycle every
every
sooner look you know uh Federal Express
I'm watching Federal Express this
morning so it's getting slaughtered yeah
like the company probably will not exist
in the future this is one of the
greatest companies
on planet Earth it's going to be
disrupted by Amazon
right so it might come back I'm sure I'm
sure some maybe Warren will come in and
figure out how to save it but
um my point of that is that like things
expire
uh bodies expire products expire ideas
expire and they run a cycle where one
either the passion's not there or the
profit's not there
and for me
you know I like to do things that are
profitable right
and uh the more profit it makes the more
passionate I get for some reason right I
can understand that so because because
that's the only way I know how to win I
can't make a basket
I can't write a movie maybe I can maybe
I could write a movie I could just yeah
I can't make it you put together some
pretty good videos I think you could
probably put together a good movie yeah
so um so look if I do a 10x growth
conference in in 12 000 people coming we
lose money on it that's nothing to be
proud about sure I know guys that can do
that we run the only
just to brag a little bit we run the
only profitable event in the world wow
everybody loses money on those deals
that's they do I did a deal with Tony
Robbins Sly Stallone Gary vaynerchuk
who else was at that gig uh I think
Pitbull was there too
two days they lost money on that gift oh
my gosh how you lose money on that wow
how do you line up
but like I'm like you got to be kidding
because they couldn't sell their tickets
they couldn't get the appropriate price
for their ticket so when do you decide
to transcend when do you decide to move
on to something look when it's no longer
passionate it's no longer profitable and
you can't figure out a solution
right you like you've tried and you're
looking at and you know that maybe the
industry's starting to go away you
mentioned that wall striding 10x rule
something changed for you yeah yeah
what was that was was that sort of this
look the typical to going all in or no
the 10x4 rules it was just the awareness
of I had been dependent upon one
vertical right and I'm sitting there
looking okay I work myself
uh I I was good at my craft I saved my
money
what did I do wrong here dude 51 years
old
I should have
I should be like so rich right now
I got I mean I should be like not even
huh where's my Jet right I wasn't even
thinking about it right I wasn't even
thinking about you I should just be like
I was still having a new business with
people I didn't like I'm like why am I
still kissing it and I don't mind
kissing like I don't mind I'll do
whatever it takes but I'm like why am I
still flying three million miles every
three years like I was banging miles out
I wasn't 150 000 miles a year wow you
know away from my family like like my
life was miserable I'm like what it's
fine that you do that for 20 years it's
not fine if you do it forever and
I'm like oh my god dude I wasn't scaling
now I didn't know that until the economy
um basically served up the lesson right
all right we're gonna take your three
businesses and we're going to show you
that we you really only have like maybe
a half of one business
took took the first business and just
cut it in half took the second business
took it down to like 90 like just killed
this partner I had and the third
business was real estate and it was
frozen it was literally like they put it
in a freezer and said you can't you're
not going to lose any of this but it's
worth nothing to you today yeah and I
was a life support
and I'm like I'll never do this again I
will never be dependent upon one
vertical one partner
or a handful of real estate I come in
today
I walk you know we we fly into London uh
we get here at 11 15. I I don't know
what I'm going to do next there's 5 000
people out there somebody sends me a
text okay this is what your day looks
like okay now now I start I start
running and hustling from one thing to
the next thing in between what I'm going
to do is I'm going to jam I'm going to
jam stuff in between events so that I
leave this I'm going to be here eight or
nine hours I'm going to leave this and
it's gonna feel like I was here eight
days
and so I'm going to jam as much in so I
don't get in trouble because the more
active I am I'm creating time basically
I'm not trying to manage time I'm not
trying to manage my day I'm trying to
create my day yeah so I I look at
everything as like I'm creating
something I'm creating always in
creation because that keeps me from
being affect
so I mean they're going to be pushing
this thing or it's going to be pushing
on me
and um
you know I'm not look I don't fly the
plane I can only push as much as my
skills allow me to yeah so I can tell
the guys from the back hey guys give us
a good straight Landing right down the
middle okay get us a little faster give
us a little higher but I'm just from the
back because I can't fly a plane
you know I'm in the back I'm in the back
of the plate you guys are doing great up
there right okay so so keep it straight
when you land right don't wreck this
thing don't damage it right I'm just
from the back yeah you guys you guys
autopilot that's all y'all do up there
right so so uh you know I make this joke
about Pilots I'm like anybody can fly a
plane not anybody not not just anyone
can buy a plane yeah right but it's a
it's a kind of a tongue-in-cheek thing
because I can't fly to play so it
doesn't matter how much I want to I
can't so I can't micromanage that but
what I can do when I'm on the plane like
last night we got on at 10 o'clock
got to the airport at 9 45 walked on the
plane beds are made
two kids a nanny Elena I'll have our
little separate beds bam we knock out we
wake up at 11 15 this morning here so
I'm refreshed ready to go and then
somebody sends me a little thing says
this is what you're doing today first
you gotta Rob Moore I said oh yeah
that dude okay so then we'll bang bang
bang and then we're gonna leave out here
about nine o'clock tonight go to Dubai
yeah and do that all over again so
that's how every day works okay except
for today when I woke up here some
somewhere this morning somebody when
they wake up is going to send me the
first thing that happens to me every
morning is I get a cash account yeah
every single day yeah so I say okay okay
nobody's stealing from me okay those
numbers are getting bigger okay that one
went down okay I know this money's going
here I need money man I got I'm playing
chess those are my pieces and if I
didn't have money it would be okay
what's my time it's either money or time
which one of my which one am I running
so look I worked at McDonald's I got
fired I worked at a furniture store I
got fired I worked in a car dealership I
was fired six times from the same guy I
just quit leaving and I've been fired so
many times I finally figured out how to
get fired and keep my job I mean really
so Talent uh I mean I'm a sales guy
because not because I wanted to that was
not something I wanted to do
uh my dad my dad was a sales guy my dad
told my mom before he died tell those
boys to learn how to sell he knew he was
going to die and he's like tell those
boys to learn how to sell and they can
go anywhere
uh I I didn't know that my mom didn't
tell me that until I was like uh 25 26
years old
and I had to take a sales job
she she wanted me to be a more a
professional
uh so I went and got an accounting
degree got out of college there was 25
unemployment I didn't know it I I you
know I didn't I didn't know anything
about sales I didn't I didn't go to
college and become a Salesman
but it was the only job I could get when
I was 25 years old it was be unemployed
or take this job selling Toyotas I
didn't even know what a Toyota was this
is this is years ago Toyota wasn't even
uh a thing yet
and
um so I took this job that I didn't I
thought it was just going to be a
temporary job I said okay I'm gonna do
this for until I can get a real job
and that ended up becoming my career I
actually hated sales
because all the jobs I had outside of
McDonald's were part-time sales jobs I
sold clothes
yeah I remember selling clothes I'd sell
I'd sell an outfit I'd make six bucks on
it
so kind of hard to get excited about six
dollars but it was six dollars more than
I had and I was trying to put myself
through college and and pay for all kind
of ridiculous things I was doing at the
time and um
I I leaned into the sales thing and
started learning it I was just shooting
some material today for Cardone
University we we have probably without
me over uh
over promoting my own product we
probably have the most
viewed sales training system in the
world today
and I'm saying that not to brag but to
tell the viewer this came out of a job I
didn't want and didn't like
but when I leaned into it and said hey I
need to commit to this thing because I'm
just gonna I have to learn how to do
this
I have to learn how to bring Revenue in
and whether I liked it or not I needed
to learn I need to learn the money game
the money game starts with in accounting
and it might have been the thing I
learned in accounting as I sit here and
tell you the story because in accounting
the top
I remember studying financial statements
in accounting classes uh it was
accounting
um the principles of accounting I
thought I was gonna learn how to make
money that's not what they're teaching
there but I remember there was on a page
in the accounting book The Blue
accounting book that I detested and
hated there was a page about an income
statement and then they would compare
income statements to these companies
well the top thing of every page was
income revenue or gross sales
and later looking back didn't know it
then but looking back later I'm like oh
that's the most important part of a
company
if it wasn't the most important part of
a company they wouldn't put it at the
top of the income State yeah on every
income statement everywhere in the world
it doesn't matter whether you're in
China or Chicago
the top three lines they might be
different words there it is all
describing gross sales uh revenue
revenue by Department
uh gross demand domestic product how
much uh revenue is coming through a
country that is what determines whether
or not a household a department or a
company is viable
and I have been fighting the top three
lines of my personal
financial statement which everybody has
one
and it's called sales so once I leaned
into it boom I started making money man
it was it was literally that simple I'm
going to learn how to bring Revenue into
my household I was 25 years old had no
money lived in a lived in an apartment
my rent was 275 dollars a month I was
laid on it four times a year
every three months I was late because
I'd go up and down
and when I leaned into it I was sitting
like hey I made an extra thousand
dollars uh when I was 25 years old I'm
like wow that was the most important
money I've ever made in my whole life
because it gave me an idea that I could
control my income I had a guy the other
day asked me for some advice okay you
know these people that asked for advice
I know you know you give it to them and
they they don't do it yeah
he knew it was true it hit him he's like
I know that's right and then he went and
did something different this is a big
mistake people make man things the best
things that have happened to me did not
require any more thought
the best decisions I've made in my life
for instant
so like my wife and I like when I
decided to buy something I go buy it I
don't check with her because that adds
thought it adds time and and this is
another bad piece of advice I was given
like take time
think about it don't move too fast take
baby steps uh you don't know nobody on
this planet ever took baby steps
they went fast and and the faster you
can go you know my plane is safest when
it's up in the air when it's Landing
slowing down it's in trouble when it's
taken off it's it's at risk that's
interesting that flight at full speed
it's almost a safety dude that thing
wants to fly
you know and and people people are being
conditioned to slow down think about it
take your time take a drug I was put on
lithium when I was 20 29 years old
because the the psychologist thought I
needed to slow down she was scared of
speed I wasn't and at that time were you
doing well financially you're doing God
was doing great but everybody's saying
hey you're doing too much of this and
you're doing too much of that and you're
going to burn and you're going to do
this and people were worried about me
around me they were going slow I was
vibrating faster than they were
but a hummingbird vibrates bumblebees
vibrate right they do things that are
impossible so
you don't want to slow down
and and you want to move with speed and
certainty that means people need to know
what they're doing
if I know what I'm doing that's why
confident people tiger won today tiger
one today you've been fighting man been
efforting 10 years he hadn't had a win
he won today that guy moves with speed
and certainty
you know winners move with speed and
certainty because they practice they
train they educate if you're having
problems right now
okay like like if you're having
recurring problems
just make a list
make a list of
make sure you guys do what Grant says
remember he's a T-Rex
yeah yeah make a list make a list of
your occurring problem
that you're sick of
the the same stuff over and over again
man I don't have enough time I don't
have enough money uh
I I don't get to take whatever the
recurring problems are I can't good good
people uh uh I I got a I got one person
in my office that I depend on and I'm
sick of depending on him even though
he's a producer
those recurring problems that you have
over and over again
uh you lose deals you lose you don't you
don't like your clients you actually
have clients that that you'd like to get
rid of you know how you get rid of that
clients get more of them
okay so what I do is if I have problems
let's say I'm making a million dollars a
year I'm making one million and I'm like
okay next year this is what this is what
business owners do
they're like um this year I'm gonna go
from 1 million to 1.2 million I'm gonna
get a little growth and then covid
cracks you
and then you're like okay I'll settle
for 500 Grand now the problem was you
were looking for incremental growth okay
you know the whole thing about three
steps forward two steps backward you
only get one step out of that by the
time by the time a week or two goes
you're like I'm sick of this I'm tired
I'm bored
I'm beat up and your life doesn't change
the trick is that if you would plan out
how to get to 10 million even though
you're not let me just go ahead and
asterisk that right now
don't have a plan to go from one to 1.2
build a plan to go from one to ten
million because it's going to give you a
new set of problems
okay and a takeaway for you today get
new problems
because if you keep working on the set
of problems that you have you will never
solve them
okay watch uh I got a handful of
problems I'm making a million dollars a
year or 200 Grand or whatever your
number is pick your number and I'm like
I'm gonna get me incremental growth how
do I do that with the people I have the
time I have the office I have
well what you do is you're like I'm
gonna go from 1 million to 10 million oh
I need a new office New problem Oh I
need 10 people not two people oh I need
to spend a hundred grand a month on
Advertising not 5 000. see all of a
sudden I got new problems
I'm no longer thinking about Pete the
the the the the uh what do they call the
guy that you're so the the diva the diva
Jessica I got to put up with Jessica's
because she's a diva comes in when she
wants leads when she wants uh she runs
the business even though I own it she
tells me what to do she's really the
boss even though I write the checks
okay so I'm like I'm gonna go get 20
Jessica's
you follow what I'm saying I'm gonna go
build like a lot of you are worried
about debt I remember in 2008 I owed 50
million dollars to the bank
and I'm like I told my wife this will
never happen to me again the bank was
pushing me around like bullying me
around like a punk
and and I said Elena this will never
ever happen to us again and she's like
what are you going to do to prevent it I
said the next time this country goes
upside down I'm gonna owe a billion
dollars in debt the problem that people
need to complain about right now is not
the billionaires they need they need to
understand that the because what they're
saying is there's income inequality
wealth inequality but the reality is
there's education inequality okay the
billionaires play by a different set of
rules than everybody else
so do I blame the guy playing by a
different set of rules or do I blame the
game you know they'll still saying about
uh don't hate the player yeah I hate the
game yeah you need to learn how to win
at the game don't hate anybody don't
hate the game don't hate the player
learn the game in the game of the
wealthy the the rules are stacked for
wealthy institutions and and wealthy
families yeah and and people need to
like understand what those rules are
yeah and those games uh those rules
those games investing yeah not spending
yeah I'm gonna I'm not gonna buy I'm not
gonna buy a house
I'm gonna buy a company yeah uh you know
Donald Trump everybody hates jobs huh
create jobs yeah I'm not going to have a
job
I'm going to create jobs like like the
difference is Donald Trump he he buys a
building in New York he lives in it
he doesn't buy a house and live in it he
buys a building and lives in it rents
out the whole place he literally gets
paid to live where he is right and then
moves into the White House so same thing
with the queen okay like like look look
at the play man yeah I mean are you
going to take the queen stuff from her
um
nobody is people been trying to take our
stuff for
70 years ain't nobody taking her stuff
so this is not a new thing this is not a
new problem like this is thousands of
years old play the game of the wealthy
own things own businesses don't spend
money yeah invest money don't waste it
on cars and bicycles and
like if you look at the average family
in in in the UK they will spend
ridiculous money on things their kids
want
look I'll take care of my kids but I
don't just frivolously buy them junk
yeah like okay it's only 89 I'm gonna
get it for them and it's worth nothing
the next day that's where that's where
the difference is yeah
and then and then the wealthy they
invest money to connect with people
okay uh most people most people go home
at night so they can be with their
family
the thinking's different so these guys
are going to go to Davos and meet with
uh Bill Gates and and and Warren Buffett
and spend Millions Making Connections
not tens of thousands millions of
dollars where the average household in
the UK is like I just want to go home
tonight watch TV and you you people are
getting punished for that do not try
the competition thing
overrated and it doesn't work and I'm
going to prove it to you right here in a
second okay is it private what's called
an FBO everybody that flies in here
owns their own aircraft
dude you don't want to try to be the
biggest jet okay you don't want to try
to beat up most money you don't want to
try to beat up like the best of the best
there'll always be somebody faster and
stronger
and richer okay don't play the game oh I
gotta be number one what does that even
mean man I got to be the biggest what
does that even mean I gotta have the
biggest car the biggest watch the
hottest chick
what does that mean it's a game you
cannot win at okay you will get your
brains handed to you I'm gonna show you
what I mean right here in a second
that's Lane right there that's a little
Learjet right there I think it's a
little Lira Phenom I don't have all my
Jets right okay I don't know that's you
can buy that plane for about 800 Grand
right next to it a little bigger
look we're throwing up right here little
Challenger
you got a little Ghost Street four right
there
that that's leaks 13. don't try to play
the game I'm the biggest
[Music]
game okay it's a losers game man I'm
gonna show you some equipment out here
because anybody like here's a little
Phenom 100
that plane's about five million bucks
great plane faster fast so fast seat
seven people okay maybe four or five
million bucks great plane great starter
plane
so look at this see that right out there
that's a 20 passenger jet right there
okay now notice what's right next to it
John
[Music]
okay that's a 727 that a hotel owned
if you try to play that game the
competition game I'm the strongest I'm
the best you lose that game
you got to find what you need in life
what's enough for you you guys got to
Define that I can't Define it for you
most people are coming up short on that
game
but there's a lot of other people that
are making the mistake when they get in
the game and they start playing they got
to keep reaching
not because they need it
but because their ego is like oh I gotta
be the biggest
and you know what you are
a hotel owns that that plane's probably
200 million dollars back there the point
is don't play I gotta be the strongest
because sooner or later you won't be
[Music]
find out what you need look look look
what's on that plane over there hey look
at my little plane look at my little
plane see you're like man Grant man man
your little plane no no no flash over to
this one
see if I'm doing a comparison thing the
competition thing it's a loser's game I
would rather fast than perfect yeah I
would rather I'd rather
I'll post something that's got
grammatical uh issues the first book I
ever wrote had hundreds of misspell
boards not a few hundreds of them
and a guy I remember a guy first person
to tell me about him I didn't see him
I wrote it it wasn't a ghost writer I
wrote the book bang bang bang bang so
um
the guy calls me says man you got
hundreds of misspelled words I I have a
spreadsheet he's trying to be of service
to me he's like he sends me a
spreadsheet grammar calling sending
colon I use semicolons where there
should be colons uh commas where there
should be periods and he's like run on
sentences and and he sends me this whole
spreadsheet like 40 pages of Corrections
I said man thanks for doing that
yeah I mean he's like uh I I just want
to be sure you get it right I said bro
it's a best-selling book it's a
best-selling
book and he's like huh I said it's a
best seller son it's not a best written
yeah it ain't a perfect grammar book
like I've never been perfect
I'm sloppy I'm I'm you know I'm I push
hard I push pass but I'd rather I'd
rather you know I remember Bill Gates
Bill Gates says look if if Microsoft
can't be the best let's make it look
like it's the best
you know when China was ripping bill off
he's like if they're gonna rip somebody
off let's make sure they rip off
Microsoft like the attitude is like get
to the market
you know get to the market be in the
market put it in put it in people's
hands we can fix it later if you look at
if you look at the the the the this
little device right here they came out
with an 11. the 11 had so many bugs in
it
every day people were getting you've
been updated
updated this code for phone was
and we had to push it out because we
want to hit our quarter yeah we want to
keep people excited with new products so
we're willing to hit people with a new
product that's got bugs in it
now the perfectionist says no no we need
to wait okay we got to get it perfect we
got to get it fixed which means you're
going to get slaughtered in the
marketplace by a beast that runs faster
and dominates the market and overwhelms
the customer with new products uh while
you're sitting back in your laboratory
saying hey we're going to make it
perfect that goes for the artist to the
businessman to the musician to everyone
to the to the this is why men have an
advantage in social media over women
because women got to do the filter got
to fix their hair got to do their makeup
or bodybuilding world champions he's got
to go pop first
tie ties back there Ty Lopez he's back
there Ty's a friend of mine he's back to
your pumping up right now you're trying
to get his PEC swollen you know so so
like like you watch you watch my social
media like like most of it's not planned
not 90 of it's not planned and I have
bad hair days I say the wrong things I
want to push the I want to push product
out I want to get I'd rather frequency
frequency and speed over quality and
I'll figure the quality out as I go 2008
happened I had nothing to do with 2008.
I had two businesses and I was starting
to buy real estate and I was not buying
the real estate to cause the problem in
this country any of you remember when
Lehman collapsed uh your business if you
were in business your business probably
got hurt
I wasn't doing the mortgage-backed
Securities I wasn't doing the no money
down houses you know I wasn't selling
that stuff I wasn't doing Mass
development on the backs of the bank uh
with bad loans but
because I lived in America and I was
doing business at the time I got greatly
affected by that my first two businesses
got cut in half and my real estate was
frozen up oh at 52 million dollars to a
bank that went upside down new bank came
in they started making demands on me I
ended up in a lawsuit aren't there a
bunch of lawyers in there yeah I ended
up I ended up in one of these crazy
lawsuits where the guy was going under
he had done some things wrong and he
decided to pull me down with it
it was a frivolous lawsuit that was
costing me 200 Grand a month to fund I
had never been involved in a lawsuit in
my career
so that being said
um
I looked at that situation and said hey
what did I do wrong here
like I always look at how am I
responsible responsible able to respond
that is the definition of responsible
able to respond now in my case I was
being forced to respond it wasn't a lot
of able in it so uh but the one thing
that I walked away with was I had a baby
on the way I just been married I just
got married Maybe
three years before that so the marriage
was very new
we were we were really still in the
honeymoon phases of our marriage not
really understanding
who we were as a team my wife and I new
baby coming along I lived in Los Angeles
I lived in a beautiful house up in the
hills uh overlooking all of LA and I
pretty much thought my life was great
until 2008 happened
now I'm taking a second to get you to to
what I want you to hear I didn't plan on
2008 I didn't think about a Lehman
collapse I didn't know 40 million people
were going to go upside down in their
homes I did not know it would affect me
I didn't know one of my Industries was
the automobile dealers I was working
with automobile dealers around the
United States that was my primary
business
I was making a couple million bucks a
year I didn't know 9 000 car dealers
would go out of business
would plan on any of that
now what's that got to do with the day
who in their business plan had covid as
part of your business plan
let us know in the chat put it put a no
in the chat if you didn't have a plan
for that yeah
yeah I need to see 316. I need to see
one
one guy in here say oh yeah I planned on
mask
oh yeah I had I had myself going out one
week buying four hundred dollars worth
of toilet paper
okay
um oh yeah in 2020 by the way how many
of you in 2020 January first you're like
this is gonna be the best year of my
life
oh yeah yeah everybody gave that up on
March 23rd the entire nation of America
gave up
surrender 2020. look the news the media
by by April was saying 2020 is over how
many of you heard that [ __ ] I'm throwing
20 20 away Fortune 500 companies 100
companies Carnival Cruise Lines General
Motors Ford Motor Company like Mass
companies were like I'm done I'm tapping
out
this year's over
a Wall Street every day I'm watching
Bloomberg right now wall Street's like
hey just throw away all the earnings for
2020. let's reboot for 2021 the entire
nation surrendered
uh your kids aren't going to schools you
didn't plan on that did you see this is
the problem with the concept I think I
saw somewhere in your promo go big or go
home what's the saying go big or go home
Say Nothing At Home Folks there ain't
nothing at your house you're not gonna
make your business work at home
okay go big or go home or home you need
to scratch that out and say look I got
to go big or I got to go bigger because
going home cannot be a choice now and
the whole country went home we've been
quarantined you're going to have 10
million probably 8 to 10 million
bankruptcies by the end of this year the
the other shoe is not dropped yet the
stock market's going crazy the rich are
getting richer and and I I don't include
us on this call as the rich the rich
will get richer
okay you why because they think big
they think that they never waste a
crisis
and we are in a crisis
and the crisis if you were in trouble
before covid you were in more trouble
today and the reason we're in trouble is
because people in this country are
satisfied complacent comfortable these
are the enemy so if you can take
anything away from me it's like look you
have you and your wife you and your
husband you and your kids must give up
ideas of comfort if you want another
amazing Grant Cardone video check it out
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there